you can't say some guys are writing on
twitter and they made you know sean king
want to sell his house that's like you
say it's just gossip
right twitter will not kill you unless
you use that social pressure in order to
achieve an action on the street and
believe well i'm going to address that
in a minute okay i want to but i want to
you could answer this first thank you i
appreciate it a couple of quick things
one forty thousand people did not
assault the capital okay it's just
factually inaccurate there are maybe a
thousand people that is not making light
of the evil of those people who all will
end up rotting in prison as they should
how many people came to that rally were
all of those people assaulting the
capital is that all marched on the
capitol and then the leading they all
marched on the capital it's just
inaccurate yeah it isn't no yes no it is
inaccurate malcolm x ben well well
you're not mentioning them okay all
right okay
let's just say some of them milled
around outside yeah
[Applause]
this is very quick i'll tell you why
that's an important point because
malcolm you have a terrible habit of
conflating people who do actual violent
activity with a broader rubric of
everyone for example who voted for trump
which was 75 million people and that
really is ugly i mean you've tweeted
about me for example that i'm such a
racist i shouldn't be allowed in
washington dc that sounds rather
authoritarian an attitude to me i've
never called for you to be kicked off of
msnbc i've never called for anybody not
to buy your book i've never called for
anybody to censor you on twitter i am
talking in my book about the attitude
that suggests that people who are
outside the overton window should meet
with not only a sort of a sort of social
uh ostracization but they should meet
with real world consequences that do
affect their lives let me tell you
something two years ago i was invited to
uh auschwitz for the auschwitz
foundation where they were holding a
conference call lecture me on the
holidays no no i'm going to tell you
what the conference was called